one of the world's most famous artists
masterpieces are on display right now at
the bellagio ready for a new home to the
highest bidder victoria saha has a
preview of picasso's auction
our enthusiasts can have one last chance
to bid on some of pablo picasso's
original artwork this one right here
could go up to 30 million dollars it's a
1969 piece depicting a man and a child
11 different pieces of artwork made by
picasso are up for grabs saturday
evening starting at 40 thousand dollars
picasso is arguably the most important
artist of the 20th century his different
art techniques range from brush strokes
on paper oil and canvas and work in
ceramic making the artist's pieces so
unique the very manifold
different applications of the way that
he worked throughout his career are all
represented here beautifully brook
lampley from sotheby's in auction house
says artwork from picasso is usually
held at auctions in big cities around
the world and to have an art auction
with picasso's original work in las
vegas will make it accessible to many in
the united states mgm has had these
original pieces for 21 years and this is
the first time they're auctioning them
off to bring in new artwork art has been
part of our dna as a company and it was
really looking at the time that it's you
know time to to grow and an opportunity
to contemporize our collection and
diversify
what we have in the collection
and you know
share now these pieces get to go and
have another history with another
collector or a museum the directors here
hoping that these walls are cleared off
by saturday night reporting from the
bellagio victoria saha live local now